Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. His Imperial and Royal Apostolic Majesty By the grace of God, Emperor of Austria, King of Hungary and Bohemia, Dalmatia, Croatia, Slavonia, Galicia, Lodomiria and Illyria, King of Jerusalem, etc., Archduke of Austria, Grand Duke of Tuscany and Krakow, Duke of Lorraine,
感谢收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需收听每周的额外剧集、无广告内容、抢先观看系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。他的帝国与皇家使徒陛下，承蒙上帝恩典，奥地利皇帝，匈牙利、波希米亚、达尔马提亚、克罗地亚、斯拉沃尼亚、加利西亚、洛多梅里亚和伊利里亚国王，耶路撒冷国王等，奥地利大公，托斯卡纳和克拉科夫大公，洛林公爵，
Salzburg, Styria, Carinthia, Carniola and Bucovina, Grand Prince of Transylvania, Margrave of Moravia, Duke of Upper and Lower Silesia, of Modena, Parma, Piacenza and Guastala, of Auschwitz and Sator, of Teschen, Friaul, Ragusa and Zara, princely count of Habsburg and Tyrol, of Khyber, Gorizia and Gradiska, prince of Trento and Brixen, margrave of Upper and Lower Lusatia and in Istria, count of Hohenems, Feldkirch, Bregenz, Sonnenberg, etc., lord of Trieste, of Kataro, and on the Vindic March, Grand Voivode of the Voivodeship of Serbia, etc. etc. So those, Tom Holland, are the titles of Franz Josef I of Austria-Hungary.
萨尔茨堡、施蒂利亚、克恩顿、卡尼奥拉和布科维纳公爵，特兰西瓦尼亚大亲王，摩拉维亚藩侯，上、下西里西亚、摩德纳、帕尔马、皮亚琴察和瓜斯塔拉公爵，奥斯威辛和扎托尔公爵，切申、弗留利、拉古萨和扎拉公爵，哈布斯堡和蒂罗尔亲王伯爵，基堡、戈里齐亚和格拉迪斯卡亲王伯爵，特伦托和布雷萨诺内亲王，上、下卢萨蒂亚和伊斯特拉藩侯，霍恩埃姆斯、费尔德基希、布雷根茨、松嫩贝格等伯爵，的里雅斯特、卡塔罗和温德马克领主，塞尔维亚大沃伊沃德等。汤姆·霍兰，这些就是奥匈帝国弗朗茨·约瑟夫一世的头衔。
And frankly, we are pretty pitiful by comparison. Only your titles, Duke of Brixton, Supreme Voivode of South London. Yeah. They pale by comparison. Yeah, we love a grand title on The Rest is History, don't we? We do. We do. And I have to say that probably, has there ever been a family in history that has had a better array of titles than the Habsburgs?
坦白说，相比之下我们真是太寒酸了。只有你的头衔，布里克斯顿公爵，南伦敦最高沃伊沃德。没错。相比之下它们显得黯然失色。是的，我们《历史的余味》节目组都很喜欢宏大的头衔，不是吗？确实如此。而且我不得不说，历史上恐怕从来没有哪个家族比哈布斯堡家族拥有更华丽的头衔了吧？
I love the Habsburgs, Tom. There's a sort of a particular Habsburg nostalgia among people who've got nothing to do with the Habsburgs, not in Central Europe at all. People like me who like going to Vienna. Eating strudel. Eating strudel, Sascha Torte. Yes, and all that. Thinking about Mahler. Yes. Yeah, you do. You're a great lover of Habsburg Vienna, aren't you? And as you know,
汤姆，我热爱哈布斯堡家族。在那些与哈布斯堡家族毫无关系的人群中，甚至在完全不在中欧的人群中，有一种独特的“哈布斯堡怀旧情结”。像我这样喜欢去维也纳的人。吃萨赫蛋糕，吃果馅卷。是的，诸如此类。思考马勒。没错。是的，你确实是哈布斯堡治下维也纳的忠实爱好者，不是吗？而且如你所知，
I am a great lover of Archdukes. There's nothing I love more than to chat away to Archdukes and so on. I've been to Franz Ferdinand's castle, Konopishta. Have you? Full of all the creatures that he shot. Some people might think that distasteful. I loved it. Anyway, that's just a tangent. Talk about Archdukes. Okay. So listeners have probably been able to gauge from the tone of abject flattery that Dominic in particular is affecting. I'm after an honour, Tom. I'm after perhaps my periods. You want to be a member of the Order of the Fleece, don't you? The Order of the Golden Fleece. I do. I absolutely do. My life will be for nothing if I'm not.
我非常热爱大公。没有什么比和大公们聊天更让我开心的了。我去过弗朗茨·斐迪南的城堡——科诺皮什特。你去过吗？里面全是那些他射杀的动物。有些人可能会觉得这很令人反感。但我很喜欢。总之，这只是个题外话。谈谈大公吧。好的。听众们可能已经从多米尼克那种卑微的奉承语气中察觉到了。汤姆，我是想求个荣誉。我可能是在追求我的……你想要成为金羊毛骑士团的一员，对吧？金羊毛骑士团。是的，我绝对想。如果不能成为其中一员，我的人生就毫无意义了。
So we talked about the Order of the Golden Fleece, which was set up by the Dukes of Burgundy with Bart Van Loo ages ago. And I saw then that your ears pricked up. I saw the glint of chivalric yearning in your gaze. So obviously, ever since then, it's been a huge ambition, not just to talk about the Habsburgs, but actually to get a Habsburg Archduke onto the podcast. And it's basically like getting a kind of member of the Julia Claudians or the Tudors or somebody. And we are very, very honored to be joined by a genuine Habsburg. Eduard Karl, Josef Michael, Marcus Antonius, Collarman, Volkard Maria, Habsburg Lotharingen, to be precise. The Archduke of Austria, better known, Edward, I think,
我们之前和巴特·范·洛（Bart Van Loo）聊过由勃艮第公爵创立的金羊毛骑士团。当时我就看到你竖起了耳朵。我看到了你眼中闪烁着骑士般的渴望。所以很明显，从那时起，这不仅是想谈论哈布斯堡家族，更是想请一位哈布斯堡大公来参加我们的播客。这基本上就像请到了一位朱里亚·克劳狄王朝或都铎王朝的成员一样。我们非常荣幸能请到一位真正的哈布斯堡家族成员。准确地说，是爱德华·卡尔·约瑟夫·米夏埃尔·马库斯·安东尼乌斯·科拉曼·沃尔卡德·玛丽亚·哈布斯堡-洛林。奥地利大公，我想，爱德华，你更广为人知的名字是，
as you're just Habsburg-Lotharingen. Aren't you on your passport? Is that right? Yes, I am. In Hungary, it's more complicated because I'm Habsburg-Lotharingen. Okay, that is complicated. And you're not just the Archduke of Austria, you are also the Hungarian ambassador to the Holy See, to the Pope. Yes, in fact, I'm ambassador here since eight years, but I am not the Archduke of Austria because there's tons of us. In fact, every single Habsburg is an Archduke or an Archduchess. We did this in a rather creative way. We found this title belonged to us in an old document. So all of us are archdukes.
在你的护照上，你只是哈布斯堡-洛林，对吧？是的，我是。在匈牙利情况更复杂，因为我是哈布斯堡-洛林。好吧，那确实很复杂。而且你不仅是奥地利大公，你还是匈牙利驻圣座（教廷）大使。是的，事实上我担任大使已经八年了，但我并不是“那位”奥地利大公，因为我们有很多人。事实上，每一位哈布斯堡家族成员都是大公或女大公。我们以一种相当有创意的方式做到了这一点。我们在一份旧文件中发现这个头衔属于我们。所以我们所有人都是大公。
There is not the archduke, but every Habsburg is archduke or archduchess. I apologize profusely. Dominic, obviously, with his detailed knowledge of Central European peerage, would not have made that crashing mistake. But I want to add that I make myself sincerely unpopular in Austria, if I even mention the word Archduke, because using that title in Austria will lead to a fine. But we're talking on an English speaking podcast outside of Austria. You would genuinely get fined if you use that title in Austria. It's complicated.
没有所谓的“那位”大公，而是每一位哈布斯堡成员都是大公或女大公。我深表歉意。多米尼克显然凭借他对中欧贵族头衔的详尽了解，是绝不会犯这种低级错误的。但我还要补充一点，在奥地利，如果我提到“大公”这个词，我会让自己非常不受欢迎，因为在奥地利使用该头衔会导致罚款。但我们是在奥地利之外的英语播客中谈论。在奥地利使用那个头衔真的会被罚款吗？情况很复杂。
If you went into a cafe and you said, I'm the Archduke, bring me hot chocolate. Someone can call the police and I can get into trouble. But I think the fine is not that high. It is a correspondent number to a rather low number of Kornen, I think. But Austria has a complicated situation here. In the rest of the world, people see this as a historic title that is stuck to the Habsburgs. And that's why they use it in speaking about the Habsburgs. Do you know, if I was an archdeacon, I'd use it all the time, even if I got a fine.
如果你走进一家咖啡馆说：“我是大公，给我拿杯热巧克力。”有人可以报警，我就会惹上麻烦。但我认为罚款金额并不高。我想是对应一个相当低的克朗数额。但奥地利的情况很复杂。在世界其他地方，人们将其视为哈布斯堡家族的某种历史头衔。这就是为什么他们在谈论哈布斯堡家族时会使用它。你知道吗，如果我是大公，我一定会一直使用它，即使会被罚款。
Yeah, I would too. So Edward, you've written a book, The Habsburg Way, Seven Rules for Turbulent Times, in which you offer the example of your family dynasty, I might almost say, as a guide to making sense of the present. But before we come to those seven rules, could we just sketch out for people who may not know much about the Habsburgs, where your family come from, and what they've done over the course of the centuries? Because they've obviously done a great deal. Well, the introductory chapter in my book, which is just a few pages, gives you an overview of our family history. I wrote that for the
是的，我也会。爱德华，你写了一本书《哈布斯堡之路：动荡时代的七条准则》，你在书中以你的家族王朝为例，作为理解当下的指南。但在我们谈论那七条准则之前，能不能为那些可能不太了解哈布斯堡家族的人简要勾勒一下，你们家族来自哪里，几个世纪以来都做了些什么？因为他们显然做了很多大事。嗯，我书中的导言章节只有几页，为你提供了我们家族历史的概览。我写那部分是为了
members in my family who are too lazy to read the entire book, but want to know a bit. Oh my God. Because being born as a Habsburg doesn't mean that you automatically know our history. As I point out, we are not like the Bene Gesserit. We don't have other memories, but we have to learn them too. So yes, a very short overview would say that we come from the romantic little corner between Germany, Switzerland, and France, where we were around the year 1200, 1250.
那些懒得读完整本书但又想了解一点的家族成员。天哪。因为生为哈布斯堡家族成员并不意味着你自动了解我们的历史。正如我指出的，我们不像贝尼·杰瑟里特（Bene Gesserit），我们没有“其他记忆”，我们也必须学习它们。所以，是的，一个非常简短的概述是，我们来自德国、瑞士和法国之间那个浪漫的小角落，大约在公元1200年到1250年左右。
We were counts in the area around the Bodensee, Limon Lake. I don't know how you say that in English. Yeah, Lake Limon, yeah. And then in 1273, the first member of our family was dragged onto the stage of world history by being elected King of the Holy Roman Empire. He was never Emperor of the Holy Roman Empire because he wasn't crowned by the Pope, but the job was the same. They thought they would choose an elderly, respectable count that will definitely never fund the dynasty and can be controlled. How wrong they were.
我们是博登湖（Bodensee，即康斯坦茨湖）周边地区的伯爵。我不知道英语怎么说。是的，莱芒湖（Lake Limon）。然后在1273年，我们家族的第一位成员被推上了世界历史的舞台，当选为神圣罗马帝国国王。他从未成为神圣罗马帝国皇帝，因为他没有被教皇加冕，但工作内容是一样的。他们以为会选出一个年长、受人尊敬的伯爵，他绝对不会资助王朝，而且可以被控制。他们错得有多离谱。
Boy, were they ever wrong. And then from 1273 to about 1918, the Habsburgs played an important role in most of the years of European history. They then sort of disappeared from the stage again for nearly 200 years because the prince electors decided never to make that mistake again. And the Habsburgs were then thrown out of Switzerland by the Swiss and took a foothold in Austria and surrounding countries and then finally made it back to the imperial throne again after a hiatus. And then a huge history begins that I could talk about for hours. So the name of Habsburg comes from this period when your ancestors have been thrown out of Switzerland and they moved to Hofburg. Is that right? Which then becomes Vienna. Am
天哪，他们错得太离谱了。从1273年到1918年左右，哈布斯堡家族在欧洲历史的大部分时间里都扮演了重要角色。之后他们从舞台上消失了近200年，因为选帝侯们决定再也不犯同样的错误。哈布斯堡家族随后被瑞士人赶出了瑞士，在奥地利及周边国家站稳了脚跟，最终在一段中断后又回到了帝国宝座。然后一段宏大的历史开始了，我可以谈上几个小时。所以哈布斯堡这个名字来自你们的祖先被赶出瑞士并搬到霍夫堡（Hofburg）的那段时期吗？是这样吗？那后来变成了维也纳。我
I misunderstanding that? No. The name Casa de Austria was used by us after having been thrown out of Switzerland. But Habsburg, of course, is a tiny little castle not too far away from Zurich in the Canton Argao in Switzerland, where a ratbot of Habsburg built that one around the year 1000. Oh, I see. Right. Yes. Sorry. And that still stands, by the way, and you can visit it. This is where our family name Habsburg comes from. When we moved to Austria, we took the more elegant title Casa de Austria
理解错了吗？不。我们在被赶出瑞士后使用了“奥地利之家”（Casa de Austria）这个名字。但哈布斯堡当然是瑞士阿尔高州苏黎世附近的一个小城堡，大约在公元1000年左右由哈布斯堡的拉德博特（Radbot）建造。哦，我明白了。对。是的，抱歉。顺便说一句，它依然屹立不倒，你可以去参观。这就是我们家族名字“哈布斯堡”的由来。当我们搬到奥地利时，我们采用了更优雅的头衔“奥地利之家”。
because it was a bit of a difficult time for the Habsburgs. They had been emperor for one moment in time, and then suddenly they were out again. They wouldn't be one of the prince electors. So they worked on their legend. That's also when we discovered the documents that proved that we were archdukes. So we'll come to the documents in a little while because I want to talk about that in the context of your rules. But at the beginning, you have five dates that you think absolutely everybody should know about the Habsburgs. So you've mentioned one of them, which is 1273, when Rudolf I, his title is King of the Romans, isn't it?
因为那对哈布斯堡家族来说是一段艰难的时期。他们曾一度成为皇帝，然后突然又出局了。他们不再是选帝侯之一。所以他们致力于打造自己的传奇。也就是在那时，我们发现了证明我们是大公的文件。我们稍后再谈这些文件，因为我想在你的准则背景下谈论它。但在开头，你有五个你认为每个人都应该了解的关于哈布斯堡家族的日期。你已经提到了其中一个，即1273年，当时鲁道夫一世的头衔是罗马人之王，对吧？
Yes. That's the Holy Roman Empire. I know it's incredibly confusing. For those people who don't know, that's effectively the kind of Leviathan that dominates Central Europe, Germany, neither Holy nor Roman nor an empire. Is it Voltaire said that, Edouard? I would disagree. I would disagree. I would disagree.
是的。那是神圣罗马帝国。我知道这非常令人困惑。对于那些不知道的人来说，那实际上是统治中欧的某种庞然大物，既不神圣，也不罗马，更不是帝国。是伏尔泰说的吗，爱德华？我不同意。我不同意。我不同意。
Okay. I know you would. So there's 1273. Now the next really important date that you identify is round about 1500. So what happens then that's so important? I would say around 1450, 1460, the Habsburgs were still a family of dreamers sitting around Vienna. And then with a series of marriages, they really explode onto the world history stage. And then after very few years, all over the lifespan of Maximilian, suddenly are everywhere in the world. They go from Austria via Burgundy to Spain and the rest of the world in very few years' time, around the year 1500. So this is when Maximilian is the one who marries the daughter of Charles the Bold,
好吧。我知道你会不同意。所以是1273年。现在你指出的下一个非常重要的日期大约是1500年。那时发生了什么如此重要的事情？我想说在1450年、1460年左右，哈布斯堡家族还是一群坐在维也纳的梦想家。然后通过一系列联姻，他们真正爆发式地登上了世界历史舞台。在马克西米利安的一生中，短短几年后，他们突然出现在世界各地。在1500年左右的短短几年内，他们从奥地利经由勃艮第走向西班牙和世界其他地方。所以这就是马克西米利安迎娶大胆查理的女儿的时候，
the Duke of Burgundy, who we talked about with Barth van Leeuwen. And so that's where the Order of the Golden Fleece and all that inheritance of lands in the Low Countries comes from. Yes, yes. And the Spanish protocol. If I begin to speak about Maximilian, you could have me for hours. He is probably one of the greatest, most romantic characters we ever had in the family. He wrote three autobiographies. They were all pimped up versions of his life as nightly adventures. He was friends with Dürer.
也就是我们和巴特·范·洛谈到的勃艮第公爵。金羊毛骑士团和低地国家的所有遗产就是从那里来的。是的，是的。还有西班牙礼仪。如果我开始谈论马克西米利安，你可以让我讲上几个小时。他可能是我们家族中最伟大、最浪漫的人物之一。他写了三部自传。它们都是他作为骑士冒险生活的夸张版本。他是丢勒的朋友。
He was friends with the greatest artists in his time. But most of all, he had no money and he sat south of Vienna in the castle of his father, when suddenly history called and he was called to marry and to save the most beautiful princess in the world. So his life suddenly became one of those nightly romances that he always read. What had happened was that Charles the Bold had somehow agreed with Maximilian's father that their children should get married. I think the deal was that he might then get the title of king from the emperor, Frederick III, father of Maximilian. And then suddenly, Charles the Bold was killed in a battle with the Swiss. And this young girl was suddenly
他是当时最伟大艺术家的朋友。但最重要的是，他没钱，坐在维也纳南部的父亲城堡里，突然历史召唤了他，他被要求去结婚，去拯救世界上最美丽的公主。于是他的生活突然变成了他一直阅读的那些骑士浪漫故事之一。发生的事情是，大胆查理不知何故与马克西米利安的父亲商定，他们的孩子应该结婚。我想交易内容是他可能从马克西米利安的父亲、皇帝腓特烈三世那里获得国王头衔。然后突然，大胆查理在与瑞士人的战斗中阵亡了。这个年轻女孩突然
the heir sitting in Burgundy, helpless, while the French king moved his armies to take Burgundy, finally take it back to France, and marry her off to his, I think, 13-year-old son. She had been writing letters with Maximilian for years, very nice. They never met, of course, as you usually never did before you got married as a Habsburg or prince at that time. And she just wrote him a letter and said, come and save me, my knight. And he, of course, had a horse and a knightly armor and a few friends and a few soldiers and no money. So he got on his horse south of Vienna and he rode up the Danube towards Burgundy.
成了勃艮第的继承人，孤立无援，而法国国王调动军队去夺取勃艮第，最终将其收回法国，并把她嫁给他当时我想是13岁的儿子。她和马克西米利安通信多年，非常美好。当然，他们从未见过面，正如当时作为哈布斯堡成员或王子结婚前通常不会见面一样。她只是写了一封信给他说：“来救我，我的骑士。”而他当然有一匹马、一套骑士盔甲、几个朋友、几个士兵，但没钱。所以他在维也纳南部骑上马，沿着多瑙河向勃艮第进发。
And on the way, more and more people joined him, bishops and princes and counts with their armies, with the soldiers. He still never had enough money, but they knew, of course, that he was the son of Emperor Frederick. So very probably going to be elected emperor of the Holy Roman Empire, too. So it paid to be on his side, I think. And he made it in time to arrive with a huge golden army and beautiful armor to Burgundy, more or less days before the French arrived. And they got immediately married. They were a beautiful couple.
一路上，越来越多的人加入他，主教、王子和伯爵带着他们的军队和士兵。他依然没有足够的钱，但他们当然知道他是皇帝腓特烈的儿子。所以很可能也会当选神圣罗马帝国皇帝。所以站在他这一边是有利可图的，我想。他及时赶到，带着一支庞大的黄金军队和美丽的盔甲抵达勃艮第，几乎就在法国人到达的前几天。他们立即结婚了。他们是一对美丽的夫妇。
He was incredibly strong, handsome, and a daring fighter, very cultivated. They read nightly novels together, like we would be watching The Crown or something together on an iPad. They write nightly novels. And their common language was Latin because they didn't speak the same language. It was a great love story. They really loved each other. And unfortunately, Mary died very soon from a writing accident. But in the meanwhile, she has given birth to important children. and with these two children the whole marrying off and building networks and taking over the
他非常强壮、英俊，是一位勇敢的战士，非常有教养。他们一起读骑士小说，就像我们现在一起在iPad上看《王冠》一样。他们读骑士小说。他们的共同语言是拉丁语，因为他们不说同一种语言。那是一个伟大的爱情故事。他们真的很爱对方。不幸的是，玛丽很快因骑马事故去世了。但在此期间，她生下了重要的孩子。而有了这两个孩子，哈布斯堡家族通过联姻政治建立网络并接管
world by marriage politics of the Habsburgs began because the key one is they have a son called Philip and he marries the heiress of Castile doesn't she and that brings in Spain and so a generation later you have Charles V I mean he's basically king of everywhere or emperor of everywhere including America except France and England including yeah vast swathes of the you have Charles V. I mean, he's basically king of everywhere or emperor of everywhere. Including America. Except France and England, including, yeah, vast swathes of the Americas. So the Habsburgs now have their hands on Spain, Burgundy, Central Europe, their heartland in Austria, just this colossal empire. I guess at that point, when you consider it contains but it's nominally much of South America, the largest empire anybody has seen.
世界的进程就开始了。因为关键在于他们有一个叫菲利普的儿子，他娶了卡斯蒂利亚的女继承人，对吧？这带来了西班牙，所以一代之后你就有了查尔斯五世。我的意思是，他基本上是到处都是国王，或者到处都是皇帝，包括美洲，除了法国和英国，包括，是的，美洲的广大地区。所以哈布斯堡家族现在掌握了西班牙、勃艮第、中欧，他们在奥地利的中心地带，这简直是一个庞大的帝国。我想在那一点上，当你考虑到它名义上包含南美洲的大部分地区时，这是任何人见过的最大的帝国。
Yes. Parts of America, parts of North America too. Yeah. Many islands in the Pacific. The Philippines are called after King Philip of Spain. Yeah. So that was the famous realm where the sun never set. Yeah. So the first global empire, the first properly global empire.
是的。美洲的部分地区，北美洲的部分地区也是。是的。太平洋上的许多岛屿。菲律宾是以西班牙国王菲利普的名字命名的。是的。所以那就是著名的“日不落帝国”。是的。所以是第一个全球帝国，第一个真正意义上的全球帝国。
Yeah. Yes. So the Habsburgs solved that problem by having two lines of the family, two branches, one of them in Spain and one of them in Vienna. And the way they cut up the world was that the Spanish looked after the world empire, Spain, Sicily, and the Austrian one looked after Austria, Hungary, Bohemia, and always the emperor of the Holy Roman Empire for about 180 years. And what they also did was getting married among each other rather frequently. So just on the two branches for a second. So you're obviously the Central European branch, aren't you? Yes. But do you have anything to
是的。是的。所以哈布斯堡家族通过拥有两个家族分支解决了这个问题，一个在西班牙，一个在维也纳。他们瓜分世界的方式是，西班牙人负责世界帝国、西班牙、西西里，而奥地利分支负责奥地利、匈牙利、波希米亚，并且在大约180年里一直担任神圣罗马帝国皇帝。他们还经常在彼此之间通婚。所以，先谈谈这两个分支。你显然是中欧分支，对吧？是的。但你和
do with the Spanish Habsburgs or have you lost touch with them? Dominic, they died out in 1700. So we don't meet them too often. Yeah. Well, that's what I was going to ask. The other date that I suggest, the third date that I suggest is the year 1700. And one of the major topics on Twitter when people talk to me is, of course, the inbreeding, the Habsburg jaw, and the marrying between the Austrian and the Spanish branch that happened several times over the centuries, which in the end, definitely, we know this nowadays, led to the last Spanish Habsburg dying absolutely incapable of having children from genetical diseases. But are there no leftover illegitimate Spanish Habsburgs?
西班牙哈布斯堡家族有什么联系吗？还是已经失去联系了？多米尼克，他们在1700年就绝嗣了。所以我们不常遇见他们。是的。好吧，那正是我要问的。我建议的另一个日期，第三个日期是1700年。当人们在推特上和我交谈时，主要话题之一当然是近亲通婚、哈布斯堡下巴，以及几个世纪以来奥地利和西班牙分支之间发生的多次通婚，这最终——我们现在肯定知道这一点——导致了最后一位西班牙哈布斯堡成员因遗传疾病完全无法生育而去世。但难道没有遗留下来的私生西班牙哈布斯堡成员吗？
You know, that's my question. So in other words, I find it implausible to imagine, given the behavior of monarchs over the centuries, that there are no little offshoots somewhere in lurking around in, you know, the back streets of Seville or something. Burgos. You mean walking through Seville and suddenly seeing a face saying, you look like me. Exactly. Exactly. Dominic, Tom, you know, as historians, that the further you go back into history, the more we are related to everyone. Yeah, we're all descended from Genghis Khan, aren't we?
你知道，这是我的问题。换句话说，考虑到几个世纪以来君主们的行为，我认为没有理由想象在塞维利亚或布尔戈斯的后街里潜伏着一些小分支是不可能的。你是说走在塞维利亚街头，突然看到一张脸说：“你看起来像我。”正是如此。正是如此。多米尼克，汤姆，你们作为历史学家知道，你追溯历史越久远，我们与每个人的亲缘关系就越近。是的，我们都是成吉思汗的后裔，不是吗？
Every European person now is somehow descended from Charlemagne. Okay. But no, the Spanish branch is definitely gone. And 1700 is a good year because this is the end of the Habsburg rule in Spain. The last Habsburg there dies. The Spanish War of Succession happens. And you only have the Austrian branch. And then for a few years, it seems that the Austrian branch will also die out, which is
现在每个欧洲人某种程度上都是查理曼大帝的后裔。好吧。但不，西班牙分支确实已经消失了。1700年是一个好年份，因为这是哈布斯堡家族在西班牙统治的终结。最后一位哈布斯堡成员在那里去世。西班牙王位继承战争爆发。然后你只剩下奥地利分支。然后有几年，似乎奥地利分支也会绝嗣，这是
probably one of the most dramatic moments in our history is Charles VI realizes that first of all, for 10 years, he doesn't have children. Then after 10 years, he has two daughters. And then he knows that he will have to find a way to make his daughter carry on the family. He goes around Europe and negotiates with every ruler. They agree to the pragmatic sanction, which is when and if Maria Theresa gets married, she adds the name of her husband to her own, and she can carry on the family. And of course, if Maria Theresa didn't have any children, that would have been it. But she had 16.
我们历史上最戏剧性的时刻之一，查理六世意识到首先，他有10年没有孩子。然后10年后，他有了两个女儿。然后他知道他必须找到一种方法让他的女儿延续家族。他走遍欧洲，与每一位统治者谈判。他们同意了《国事诏书》，即当玛丽亚·特蕾西亚结婚时，她将丈夫的名字加到自己的名字中，她就可以延续家族。当然，如果玛丽亚·特蕾西亚没有孩子，那也就结束了。但她生了16个。
Yeah. And that restarted the Habsburgs around 1740 onwards. And it's no coincidence that she won the female Habsburg championship on Twitter. You're aware I did a Habsburg championship on Twitter where I very democratically asked people to vote for their favorite Habsburgs. I began with 16 male and 16 female. And then, you know, like in a football championship,
是的。这让哈布斯堡家族从1740年左右重新开始了。她赢得了推特上的“女性哈布斯堡冠军”并非巧合。你知道我在推特上举办过哈布斯堡冠军赛，我非常民主地请人们投票选出他们最喜欢的哈布斯堡成员。我从16位男性和16位女性开始。然后，你知道，就像足球锦标赛一样，
we went down four, two can go on to the next round. And in the end, among the males, you have blessed Emperor Karl. I know why he won. I was pretty certain he would win in the male team. But Maria Theresia won. And she's really incredible because her taking over of the empire is one of the most dramatic things in Habsburg history. Her father died rather unexpectedly.
我们进入了下一轮，四进二。最后，在男性中，你有受祝福的卡尔皇帝。我知道他为什么赢。我很确定他会在男性组中获胜。但玛丽亚·特蕾西亚赢了。她真的很不可思议，因为她接管帝国是哈布斯堡历史上最戏剧性的事情之一。她的父亲去世得相当突然。
He hadn't really prepared her for this. She was by then married, had her first children. And immediately when his father died, Frederick of Prussia began to move his armies towards Silesia. This is Frederick the Great. Yes, Frederick the Great. You know, my grandfather always used to say, Frederick of Prussia, who some call the Great. The Duke of Bavaria immediately moved his armies into Austria and said, I am the Archduke. You know, the pragmatic sanction doesn't count. She was alone.
他并没有真正为她做好准备。她当时已经结婚，有了第一批孩子。就在她父亲去世时，普鲁士的腓特烈开始调动军队向西里西亚进发。这就是腓特烈大帝。是的，腓特烈大帝。你知道，我祖父总是说：“普鲁士的腓特烈，有些人称他为大帝。”巴伐利亚公爵立即将他的军队开进奥地利，并说：“我是大公。你知道，《国事诏书》不算数。”她孤身一人。
She wasn't a soldier. She had a crumbling empire, a badly shaped army, bad finances, and old ministers. And then she showed what she was made of. She was incredibly dynamic, and she went to the Hungarians. So, you know, one of the topics of my book is the complicated relationship between the Habsburgs and Hungary. And that's also the topic of the introduction by Viktor Orban. The Hungarians weren't exactly enthusiastic to be ruled by the Habsburgs. And Mary Theresa just went to Hungary and begged the Hungarians for help against Frederick of Prussia. And they said yes, because she stood there with her young son, Joseph, and all of that. And then she worked tirelessly, had 16 children, went out, danced, was cheerful, played cards. And many aristocrats remember how they were nearly ruined by playing cards with her. And at the same time was a very good Catholic and built a network. She really reestablished the Habsburgs in 1740 to 1780. And then the next big date, 1806, because that is the date when, under pressure from Napoleon, Francis II dissolves the Holy Roman Empire.
她不是一名士兵。她拥有一个正在崩溃的帝国、一支形状糟糕的军队、糟糕的财政和老迈的大臣。然后她展示了她的实力。她非常有活力，她去了匈牙利。所以，你知道，我书中的主题之一是哈布斯堡家族与匈牙利之间复杂的关系。这也是维克多·欧尔班（Viktor Orban）所写导言的主题。匈牙利人并不完全热衷于被哈布斯堡家族统治。玛丽亚·特蕾西亚只是去了匈牙利，恳求匈牙利人帮助她对抗普鲁士的腓特烈。他们答应了，因为她带着她年幼的儿子约瑟夫站在那里，诸如此类。然后她不知疲倦地工作，生了16个孩子，出去跳舞，开朗，打牌。许多贵族记得他们是如何因为和她打牌而几乎破产的。同时她是一位非常虔诚的天主教徒，并建立了一个网络。她确实在1740年到1780年间重建了哈布斯堡家族。然后下一个大日期是1806年，因为那是弗朗茨二世在拿破仑的压力下解散神圣罗马帝国的日期。
Yes. creation is gone, but a new multinational creation exists, which is effectively the Austrian Empire, or as it becomes with the compromise of 1867, the Austro-Hungarian Empire. Does that mark a kind of a narrowing of the horizons for the Habsburgs, do you think? In a way, yes, and in a way not anymore, because by 1806, it wasn't the world empire anymore, and the Holy Roman Empire wasn't what it was anymore a few hundred years before that. But in a way, it doesn't change anything because that's one of the topics of my book,
是的。创造物消失了，但一个新的多民族创造物存在了，即实际上是奥地利帝国，或者正如1867年妥协后所称的奥匈帝国。你认为这标志着哈布斯堡家族视野的某种狭隘化吗？在某种程度上是，在某种程度上不再是，因为到1806年，它不再是世界帝国了，神圣罗马帝国也不再是几百年前的样子了。但在某种程度上，它什么也没改变，因为这是我书中的主题之一，
especially the third point in my book, is the principles that they used from 1273 on and that ruled the way they were Holy Roman emperors became the principles of the Austrian empire. And whenever the Habsburgs did that right, it was fantastic. The Austro-Hungarian empire did many things right. My very humble opinion, the European Union still has to learn to get right.
尤其是书中第三点，是他们从1273年开始使用并统治他们作为神圣罗马帝国皇帝方式的原则，成为了奥地利帝国的原则。每当哈布斯堡家族做对了，效果就非常棒。奥匈帝国做了很多正确的事情。以我非常谦卑的观点，欧盟还有很多需要学习的地方。
And one of the reasons for Brexit, I think, is because of our English friends not absolutely feeling respected in their vision. So the EU is not Habsburg enough. You said that. You said that. And so your final date is the 12th of November, 1918. And that is the date that you mentioned him earlier. So the Emperor Karl, he is the heir of Franz Josef the very famous kind of gigantic mustachioed emperor that everybody equates with kind of the 19th century. And Dominic, you talked about him, didn't you, on our 12 Days of Christmas episodes? I love him. He's very stoical. I love a dull
我认为英国脱欧的原因之一，是因为我们的英国朋友在他们的愿景中没有完全感到被尊重。所以欧盟还不够“哈布斯堡化”。你说了。你说了。所以你的最后一个日期是1918年11月12日。那是你之前提到他的日期。所以卡尔皇帝，他是弗朗茨·约瑟夫的继承人，那位每个人都等同于19世纪的、留着巨大胡子的著名皇帝。多米尼克，你在我们的“圣诞12天”剧集中谈到过他，不是吗？我爱他。他非常坚忍。我喜欢沉闷的
monarch, Tom, as you know, so I love George V. Yes, I know you do. Yes. And the more abstemious, unfun-loving. I love a monarch who gets up at four o'clock in the morning, has a cold shower, and then does his paperwork. Did he collect stamps? He's the kind of man who would, I think, Tom, even if he didn't. Right. He's a stamp collector in his soul. I think we should say that. Anyway, he's dead. That's the end of him. First World War. Karl comes in and Karl is booted out. Edouard, a very sad moment for you. Some listeners, who you would obviously absolutely have no time for, be saying this is a tremendous moment. The Republican listeners, I mean, he's booted out, but he doesn't abdicate. Isn't that right? He tries to come back to Hungary and reclaim his crown. So is there a
君主，汤姆，如你所知，所以我喜欢乔治五世。是的，我知道你喜欢。是的。而且越节制、越不喜欢享乐。我喜欢一个早上四点起床、洗冷水澡，然后处理文书工作的君主。他收集邮票吗？我想他就是那种人，汤姆，即使他没有。对。他灵魂深处是个邮票收藏家。我想我们应该这么说。总之，他死了。那是他的终点。第一次世界大战。卡尔上台，然后卡尔被踢出局。爱德华，对你来说这是一个非常悲伤的时刻。一些听众，你显然完全不会理会他们，会说这是一个伟大的时刻。共和主义听众，我是说，他被踢出局了，但他没有退位。不是吗？他试图回到匈牙利并收回他的王冠。所以，
slight sense, I don't want you to give away state secrets, family secrets, but is there a sense in your Habsburg WhatsApp group that you're all waiting for the moment when you can put right- Waiting for the call. Yeah, when you can put right what happened on the 12th of November, 1918? Yeah. History doesn't repeat itself, but it rhymes. So I say crazier things have happened in history. I don't see monarchy coming back in Austria or Hungary right now, but as I said, crazier things have happened. Okay, that's a politician's answer. I'm a diplomat. Well, I think at some point in your book, you do say, you know, no Habsburgs are dreaming of coming back, brackets, or are they?
有没有一种轻微的感觉——我不想让你泄露国家机密、家族机密——但在你们的哈布斯堡WhatsApp群里，你们都在等待那个可以纠正错误的时刻——等待召唤。是的，当你们可以纠正1918年11月12日发生的事情时？是的。历史不会重复自己，但会押韵。所以我说历史上发生过更疯狂的事情。我目前没看到君主制在奥地利或匈牙利回归，但正如我所说，发生过更疯狂的事情。好吧，那是政客的回答。我是外交官。好吧，我想在你的书中某处，你确实说：“没有哈布斯堡成员梦想着回来，（括号）或者他们有吗？”
So, I mean, I think the question of what a Habsburg Europe might look now is a very interesting one that is opened up by the list of seven rules that you have given in your book. I think we should take a break now. Maybe when we come back, just very quickly, we could skim through these seven rules to try and get a sense of what the lessons of history are for politicians in Europe and perhaps beyond today. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes,
所以，我的意思是，我认为哈布斯堡式的欧洲现在可能是什么样子是一个非常有趣的问题，这由你在书中给出的七条准则所开启。我想我们现在应该休息一下。也许当我们回来时，我们可以很快浏览一下这七条准则，试图了解今天欧洲乃至欧洲以外的政客们可以从历史中吸取什么教训。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐的余味》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦的地方。在我们的问答环节，我们揭开娱乐业的幕布，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集，
and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. We are talking about Habsburg history. We're in fact talking to a Habsburg about his own history, or rather he's talking to us. That is, of course, Edward Habsburg, the Hungarian ambassador to the Holy See, a man who could go into a Viennese cafe and introduce himself as an archduke,
以及抢先获得现场演出门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的余味》。我们正在谈论哈布斯堡历史。事实上，我们正在与一位哈布斯堡成员谈论他自己的历史，或者更确切地说，他在和我们谈论。当然，那就是爱德华·哈布斯堡，匈牙利驻圣座大使，一个可以走进维也纳咖啡馆并介绍自己是大公的人，
but he would face a fine for doing so. So Edward, I think this is your chance to brandish that title as much as you can. There is no fines on the rest of his history. We completely acknowledge you as Archduke of Austria. So you have these seven rules that you think Europe should emulate. And these are the lessons to be drawn from Habsburg history. And so we're going to go through the seven and we'll pick a historical example or two for each one to sort of anchor them in the family story. So your very first rule is get married and have lots of children.
但他会因为这样做而面临罚款。所以爱德华，我想这是你尽可能挥舞那个头衔的机会。《历史的余味》节目组没有罚款。我们完全承认你是奥地利大公。所以你有这七条你认为欧洲应该效仿的准则。这些是从哈布斯堡历史中汲取的教训。所以我们将逐一讨论这七条，并为每一条挑选一两个历史例子，以将它们锚定在家族故事中。所以你的第一条准则是：结婚并多生孩子。
Now, some people would think that's very deleterious to your family income, the more children you have, because children are very expensive. But also, I mean, quite distracting these days, I'd have thought. Isn't it? Very distracting, Tom. Yeah. Particularly you're a prime minister or something, or president. Well, Edward is going to put us right. So explain to us, Edward, what's the gist of this? Well, the gist is, of course, I'm married and have six children. So I want everybody else to experience the same sense of happiness and fulfillment that I experienced from this marriage. I'm married since 28 years now, and it's cool. No, that's not just trying to convince everybody else, but it's also, I believe that a society
现在，有些人会认为这对你的家庭收入非常有害，孩子越多，因为孩子非常昂贵。而且，我的意思是，如今这相当令人分心，我想。不是吗？非常令人分心，汤姆。是的。特别是如果你是首相或总统之类的。好吧，爱德华会纠正我们的。所以向我们解释一下，爱德华，重点是什么？嗯，重点当然是，我结婚了，有六个孩子。所以我希望其他人也能体验到我从这段婚姻中体验到的同样的幸福感和成就感。我结婚28年了，这很酷。不，那不仅仅是试图说服其他人，而且我相信一个拥有
with large families is a good society. I think that around the dinner table, you learn all the values that you need for a just, for a merciful, and you learn all the virtues you need in modern democracy. You learn to look after your younger siblings, for instance, and all of that you learn in the big family. I mean, looking at the lessons of history, did the fact that the Habsburgs, you know, I mean, you talked about Maria Theresa having 16 children. Was that helpful for the Habsburgs or Maximilian having all his children?
大家庭的社会是一个好社会。我认为在餐桌旁，你学习到了公正、仁慈所需的所有价值观，你学习到了现代民主所需的所有美德。你学会了照顾你的弟弟妹妹，例如，所有这些你都在大家庭中学习到。我的意思是，看看历史教训，哈布斯堡家族的事实，你知道，我的意思是，你谈到玛丽亚·特蕾西亚有16个孩子。这对哈布斯堡家族有帮助吗？或者马克西米利安拥有他所有的孩子？
Well, Maximilian is the big one, isn't he? Because marital diplomacy is the key to his success, isn't it, Edward? Okay, Tom, first to your question, there is a very nice quote. I think it's by Ferdinand II. He said, daughters should in all cases be welcome because they unite different countries. Sons, on the other hand, might tear one country apart. So yes, in Habsburg history, it wasn't always easy to have sons. It was always useful to have daughters because you use them in chips in marriage diplomacy.
嗯，马克西米利安是那个大人物，不是吗？因为婚姻外交是他成功的关键，不是吗，爱德华？好的，汤姆，先回答你的问题，有一句非常好的名言。我想是斐迪南二世说的。他说：“女儿在任何情况下都应该受到欢迎，因为她们联合了不同的国家。而儿子，另一方面，可能会撕裂一个国家。”所以是的，在哈布斯堡历史上，拥有儿子并不总是容易的。拥有女儿总是很有用的，因为你把她们当作婚姻外交中的筹码。
And this is to your point, Dominic. What Maximilian did in the 15th, 16th century was incredible because first he used his two children to get the Spanish empire. Then he used their children to get the Hungarian and Bohemian crown. And that was all Maximilian over several years. And he, of course, married off his grandchildren while they were still very small. They weren't actually, of course, married, but it was all agreed upon. One of them, even before he was born, it was like, if yours is a boy and mine is a daughter,
这正是你的观点，多米尼克。马克西米利安在15、16世纪所做的事情是不可思议的，因为首先他利用他的两个孩子获得了西班牙帝国。然后他利用他们的孩子获得了匈牙利和波希米亚王冠。那都是马克西米利安在几年内完成的。而且他当然在孙辈还很小的时候就把他们嫁出去了。他们当然实际上并没有结婚，但一切都商定好了。其中一个，甚至在他出生之前，就像是：“如果你的孩子是男孩，我的是女儿，
then they get married. Just one final point on the whole marrying business. And you touched on it in the first half. And this is the issue of inbreeding and the Habsburg jaw. And I can't help noticing, gazing at you on our video call, that you're a very handsome man and that your jaw is impeccably shaped and framed. Why, thank you, Tom. Tom, I can't believe you're flirting with the Archdeacon of Austria. Shameless behavior. So talk us through the Habsburg jaw.
那么他们就结婚。”关于整个婚姻业务的最后一个观点。你在上半场提到了它。这就是近亲通婚和哈布斯堡下巴的问题。在我们的视频通话中看着你，我忍不住注意到你是一个非常英俊的男人，你的下巴形状和轮廓无可挑剔。谢谢你，汤姆。汤姆，我不敢相信你在调戏奥地利大公。无耻的行为。所以向我们介绍一下哈布斯堡下巴。
Where does it come from? Where does it go? And is it true that all Habsburgs are into bread or not? This is a very good and important question. I'm thankful that you make it. There was an article in The Economist about two years ago about that, that led to all sort of inbreeding jokes on my Twitter account, as you can imagine. So, first of all, yes, it is true.
它从哪里来？它去向何方？所有哈布斯堡成员都是近亲通婚是真的吗？这是一个非常好且重要的问题。我很感谢你提出它。大约两年前《经济学人》上有一篇关于这个的文章，正如你可以想象的那样，这导致了我的推特账户上出现了各种近亲通婚的笑话。所以，首先，是的，这是真的。
The Habsburgs did marry dozens of times between the Austrian and the Spanish branch between the 16th and the 17th century. Yes, that's true. And yes, that led to genetic mutations and deformations in the later Habsburgs in the Spanish branch. However, it's very important to realize that the Habsburg jaw that looks spectacular, it's the lower mandible standing out very strongly, doesn't come from the inbreeding. And, you know, there's a famous joke, the French diplomat reports home saying that Charles V played tennis. It was jeu de paume at the time. And it rained and the drops came into his mouth. And he complained to his teacher that the drops came into his mouth.
哈布斯堡家族在16世纪到17世纪之间在奥地利和西班牙分支之间通婚了数十次。是的，那是真的。是的，这导致了后来西班牙分支哈布斯堡成员的基因突变和畸形。然而，非常重要的一点是，看起来很壮观的哈布斯堡下巴——下颌骨非常突出——并不是来自近亲通婚。而且，你知道，有一个著名的笑话，法国外交官报告说查尔斯五世打网球。当时是手掌球戏。下雨了，雨滴落进他的嘴里。他向老师抱怨雨滴落进他的嘴里。
And the teacher told him, well, then close the mouth, which solved the problem for him. Very ironically, he writes all of that. So they had a very, very strong forward-jutting lower jaw, but that happened before the Spanish branch even existed. That happened in the generation above Maximilian, and nobody married any Habsburgs then at that time. It came from Zimburga, who was his, I think, Polish grandmother. And I suppose it was probably made more prominent, perhaps, by the inbreeding, but it doesn't come from the famous Habsburg inbreeding.
老师告诉他：“好吧，那就闭上嘴。”这为他解决了问题。他非常讽刺地写下了这一切。所以他们有一个非常、非常向前突出的下颌，但这在西班牙分支存在之前就发生了。那发生在马克西米利安上一代，当时没有人与任何哈布斯堡成员结婚。它来自津布尔加（Zimburga），我想那是他的波兰祖母。我想它可能因为近亲通婚而变得更加突出，但它并不来自著名的哈布斯堡近亲通婚。
Another point I make in my book, too, is that among those 74 marriages—I think it was 74 altogether over 150 years between Vienna and Madrid—ne all of them were very, very happy marriages, not because they were cousins, but because they had the same set of values, the same faith, the same ideas about marriage, about family. They had the same sense of humor. They lived in a very similar cultural world. And so they married someone they never met, but they met somebody who came from a world they couldn't understand. To be fair, Edward, we've talked before in the podcast about a very different family who are famous for interbreeding, which is the Ptolemies, the descendants of Ptolemy
我在书中提出的另一点是，在那74次婚姻中——我想在维也纳和马德里之间150年里总共有74次——并非所有婚姻都是非常、非常幸福的婚姻，不是因为他们是表亲，而是因为他们拥有相同的价值观、相同的信仰、相同的婚姻观、家庭观。他们有相同的幽默感。他们生活在非常相似的文化世界中。所以他们嫁给了一个从未见过面的人，但他们遇到的是一个来自他们能理解的世界的人。公平地说，爱德华，我们之前在播客中谈论过一个非常不同的家族，他们以近亲通婚而闻名，那就是托勒密家族，亚历山大大帝的朋友和某种船长的后裔，他们接管了埃及。他们互相结婚，然后发生了最可怕的家族世仇，总是互相谋杀、密谋之类的。而哈布斯堡家族实际上似乎从未真正那样做过。当你审视历史时，统治历史的家族通常因为他们都互相憎恨而闻名。但哈布斯堡家族很不寻常，他们似乎相处得相当好。你认为呢？
Alexander the Great's friend and kind of captain who take over Egypt. And they married each other and then had the most hideous family feuds and sort of always murdering each other and plotting and stuff. And the Habsburgs never really seemed to have done that, actually. When you look at the history, families who dominate history are often famous because they all hate each other. But the Habsburgs are quite unusual, and they do seem to have rubbed along pretty well. You think?
亚历山大大帝的朋友，也是某种意义上接管埃及的将领。他们互相通婚，然后陷入了最可怕的家族纷争，总是互相残杀、密谋等等。事实上，哈布斯堡家族似乎从未真正那样做过。当你审视历史时，那些主宰历史的家族之所以出名，往往是因为他们彼此仇恨。但哈布斯堡家族相当不同，他们似乎相处得相当融洽。你觉得呢？
I mean, I'm not just making another play for the Golden Fleece. I think I'm well ahead of you there. There are remarkably few kind of coups, palace plots, conspiracies, all these kinds of things. So is there a genuine esprit de corps, do you think, among the Habsburgs at their peak in, I don't know, the 18th or 17th century or whatever? Dominic Flattery will get you anywhere. Brilliant. But you will remember that I complimented your chin. Yes.
我的意思是，我不仅仅是在为获得金羊毛骑士团勋章做另一番努力。我想在这方面我比你领先很多。像政变、宫廷阴谋、密谋之类的勾当非常少见。那么，你认为在哈布斯堡家族的鼎盛时期，比如18或17世纪，他们之间是否存在真正的团队精神？多米尼克·弗莱特里（Dominic Flattery）能让你无往不利。太棒了。但你要记得，我夸过你的下巴。是的。
If you're deciding which of us is to join the Order of the Golden Fleece, just remind me of that. So I think there's two reasons why the Habsburgs are an awfully nice family without backstabbing murder and horrible things. One of them is that from the beginning, they had to look after an incredibly complex set of countries, had to be very diplomatic and couldn't afford power games, violence. There were a few moments where family insight intrigues in the early times. But apart from that, they were always, you're absolutely right, a very esprit de corps and they were all Catholic.
如果你在决定我们俩谁能加入金羊毛骑士团，记得提醒我这一点。所以我认为哈布斯堡家族之所以是一个非常好的家族，没有背后捅刀子的谋杀和可怕的事情，有两个原因。其中之一是，从一开始，他们就必须照顾一套极其复杂的国家体系，必须非常外交，负担不起权力游戏和暴力。在早期，确实有几次家族内部的勾心斗角。但除此之外，他们一直都非常有团队精神，而且他们都是天主教徒，这一点你是完全正确的。
Right. So this is your second rule, isn't it? Yes. Your second rule is be a Catholic. Dominic pulling a very Protestant face at that. So could you just talk through that? Why you think that's significant for the success of the Habsburgs over the sweep of history? I think that the Habsburgs saw their job of being emperor or being archduchess married out somewhere as part of their vocation as catholics and as christians and as something they would one day have to render accountability to god in the last judgment nowadays we're used to cultural catholics or salon catholics or catholics by baptism but
对。所以这是你的第二条准则，对吧？是的。你的第二条准则是做一个天主教徒。多米尼克露出了非常新教徒的表情。那么你能详细谈谈吗？为什么你认为这对哈布斯堡家族在整个历史进程中的成功至关重要？我认为哈布斯堡家族将他们作为皇帝或外嫁的帝国女大公的工作，视为他们作为天主教徒和基督徒的使命的一部分，也是他们终有一天在最后审判中必须向神负责的事情。如今我们习惯了文化天主教徒、沙龙天主教徒或受洗的天主教徒，但
you were a serious catholic in the 15 16 17 18th, 17th, 18th century. Well, 18th century, you had the Enlightenment. Things got a bit different. But the faith was something that shaped your every decision. And you thought twice about doing something nasty because you knew that you could, of course, go to confession. But in the end, God would ask you, you were emperor over your people. Did you do this right? And this was a serious
在15、16、17、18世纪，你是一个虔诚的天主教徒。好吧，18世纪有了启蒙运动，情况有所不同。但信仰是塑造你每一个决定的东西。你在做坏事之前会三思，因为你知道你当然可以去忏悔。但最终，上帝会问你，你是你子民的皇帝。你做对了吗？这是一个严肃的
matter. So the Habsburgs took their faith very serious. You could even say a joke like, are the Habsburgs Catholic? It's almost like, is the Pope Catholic? They were always Catholic, and they still are. I may add our like four to 500 family members that still hang around. Most of us are active Catholics, devout Catholics. We still have lots of children. So it's something that shaped our family a lot. And yes, I believe that it led to the harmonious parts of our family history. Could I just ask about one very celebrated Habsburg who seems not to have been perhaps as orthodox in his Catholicism as he might have been, and that is Rudolf II. He's based in Prague, isn't he? Towards
问题。所以哈布斯堡家族非常认真地对待他们的信仰。你甚至可以开个玩笑说，哈布斯堡家族是天主教徒吗？这就像问教皇是天主教徒吗一样。他们一直都是天主教徒，现在依然是。我还可以补充说，我们大约有四到五百名家族成员仍然活跃着。我们大多数人都是积极的天主教徒，虔诚的天主教徒。我们仍然有很多孩子。所以这是塑造我们家族的重要因素。是的，我相信这带来了我们家族史上和谐的部分。我能问一个非常著名的哈布斯堡成员吗？他似乎在天主教信仰上并不像他本应表现得那样正统，那就是鲁道夫二世。他住在布拉格，对吧？在
the end of the 16th century. And he's a great enthusiast for alchemy and secret rites and all kinds of things like that. And he refused the sacrament on his deathbed, didn't he? He had no time for all this. Carry on. He and his father both did that. Very, very dark moment in our family history. So they're the dark sheep. In a way they are, in a way they are. And I regularly pray for them. On the other hand, it was difficult to be a Holy Roman Emperor in a moment where Protestantism and the Reformation broke into the German lands. And I mean, the Holy Roman Empire was mostly centered around the German speaking lands. And half of your princes suddenly were Protestant.
16世纪末。他非常热衷于炼金术、秘密仪式以及各种类似的事情。他在临终时拒绝了圣礼，对吧？他没时间搞这些。继续说。他和他的父亲都那样做了。这是我们家族史上非常、非常黑暗的时刻。所以他们是害群之马。在某种程度上是的，在某种程度上是的。我经常为他们祈祷。另一方面，在宗教改革和新教进入德意志地区的时候，做一个神圣罗马帝国皇帝是很困难的。我的意思是，神圣罗马帝国主要集中在德语地区。而你的一半诸侯突然变成了新教徒。
And you somehow had to come to grips with that and somehow had to live with that situation. And people like later Ferdinand II, they sort of stood strong and even too strong. I mean, people hated them. Yeah, I was going to say Ferdinand II. I mean, he's ultra-Catholic, isn't he? He's identified with the Counter-Reformation. He's one of the great protagonists of the Thirty Years' War. But maybe, Edward, you will say I've been reading too much Protestant historiography, because in a lot of the histories of the Thirty
你必须以某种方式应对这种情况，并以某种方式与这种局面共存。像后来的斐迪南二世这样的人，他们表现得很强硬，甚至太强硬了。我的意思是，人们恨他们。是的，我正想说斐迪南二世。我的意思是，他是极端天主教徒，对吧？他与反宗教改革运动紧密相连。他是三十年战争的伟大主角之一。但也许，爱德华，你会说我读了太多的新教史学，因为在很多关于三十年
Years' War, the implication is if he had been less Catholic, if he had been less insistent on orthodoxy and maybe more tolerant of the Protestant princes, the great bloodbath of the 30 Years' War might not have unfolded. Now I know I'm talking myself out now of that honor, but I'm going to stick with it anyway. Keep going, Dominic. Keep digging. So what's your take on Ferdinand II? Because you did hint there that he might have been too Catholic.
战争的历史中，暗示是如果他没那么天主教，如果他没那么坚持正统，也许对新教诸侯更宽容一些，三十年战争那场大屠杀可能就不会发生了。现在我知道我正在推翻自己的观点，但我还是要坚持下去。继续，多米尼克。继续深挖。那么你对斐迪南二世有什么看法？因为你刚才暗示他可能太天主教了。
I'm a diplomat and my heart tells me he was a good Catholic emperor. The diplomat in me sees that he could have achieved things, like Kissinger says in his book on diplomacy, where he says the absolute not understanding by Richelieu how Ferdinand could be so stupid not to make small steps to achieve something for Austria. The Catholic in me says because Ferdinand remained firm, Austria is still Catholic. The diplomat in me says, well, he could have made some agreements
我是一名外交官，我的内心告诉我他是一位好的天主教皇帝。我作为外交官的那一面看到，他本可以实现一些目标，就像基辛格在他的外交著作中所说的那样，他提到黎塞留完全无法理解斐迪南怎么会如此愚蠢，不采取小步骤为奥地利争取利益。我作为天主教徒的那一面说，因为斐迪南立场坚定，奥地利至今仍是天主教国家。我作为外交官的那一面说，好吧，他本可以达成一些协议，
and perhaps we would have had less problems also with Prague and with Bohemia and with these parts of the event. So we don't know. It went the way it went. If you look at the history of Ferdinand II and the way he was raised, educated, shaped, the vows he made to keep Austria Catholic. He couldn't have gone any other way.
也许我们在布拉格、波希米亚以及这些地区的麻烦也会少一些。所以我们不知道。事情就是这样发生的。如果你看看斐迪南二世的历史，以及他的成长、教育、塑造方式，他为保持奥地利天主教信仰所做的誓言。他不可能走别的路。
In my book, I say I think that he did the right thing. Of course, I do because I'm a Habsburg. But as I said, the diplomat in me understands your position. But we can rarely ask the question, what would have happened if? It's not allowed to historians we for instance could ask if franz ferdinand's car yeah wouldn't have stopped and turned around at exactly that point where gavriel prince of by coincidence was walking after his first attempt imagine no first world war yeah two years later emperor franz ferdinand with a very balanced view of the Slavic people in his empire. No Germany humiliated by Versailles, no fertile ground for Hitler, no Second World War. Imagine, but you can't do that.
在我的书中，我说我认为他做了正确的事。当然，我这么说是因为我是哈布斯堡家族的人。但正如我所说，我作为外交官的那一面理解你的立场。但我们很少能问“如果……会怎样？”的问题。历史学家是不允许这样做的。例如，我们可以问，如果弗朗茨·斐迪南的车没有在加夫里洛·普林西普碰巧走过的那一点停下并掉头，想象一下没有第一次世界大战，两年后，弗朗茨·斐迪南皇帝以一种非常平衡的眼光看待帝国中的斯拉夫民族。没有被凡尔赛条约羞辱的德国，没有希特勒的温床，没有第二次世界大战。想象一下，但你不能那样做。
This is music to my ears. We should have done a deal and turned on the French. Edward, there's no doubt about that. This is shameless, shameless power play. So that actually kind of leads us on to the third point that you make, which is believe in empire and subsidiarity. Now, subsidiarity is a word that's very popular in the EU, isn't it? The idea that you kind of cede power back to the various parts of the imperial entity. But enthusiasm for empire isn't something that you tend to get these days. So what's the justification for empire? In my book, I speak about the difference between the empire in Star Wars and in Dune, in the Dune novels, and of course in the movie too. Our idea of empire is a ruthless power
这简直是天籁之音。我们本应该达成协议，然后转而对付法国人。爱德华，毫无疑问。这是无耻的，无耻的权力游戏。这实际上引出了你提出的第三点，即相信帝国和辅助性原则。现在，“辅助性”是一个在欧盟非常流行的词，不是吗？即你将权力下放给帝国实体的各个部分。但对帝国的热情在今天并不常见。那么帝国的正当性是什么？在我的书中，我谈到了《星球大战》和《沙丘》小说（当然还有电影）中的帝国与现实中帝国的区别。我们对帝国的概念是，一个皇帝对许多不同的国家进行无情的权力
grab by one emperor over many, many different countries that are all uniform places where armies enforce obedience, and then a band of rebels, Luke Skywalker, et cetera, fight against that. The Holy Roman Empire was very different. And I think that's probably the central chapter in my book about subsidiarity, is the Habsburg Empire only worked and only worked well when the lower levels, the single nations, the single peoples were respected by the Habsburg Empire only worked and only worked well when the lower levels, the single nations, the single peoples were respected by the Habsburgs. From the beginning, you have that in the 13th century, you have Charles V writing this to
掠夺，这些国家都是统一的地方，军队强制执行服从，然后一群反叛者，卢克·天行者等人，与此抗争。神圣罗马帝国则大不相同。我认为这可能是我书中关于辅助性原则的核心章节，即哈布斯堡帝国只有在下层，即单一民族、单一人民受到哈布斯堡家族尊重时，才能运作良好。从一开始，13世纪就有查理五世写给
his son as a rule, and you have it up to the very last moment. I love the quote you give from Francis II, who was emperor during Napoleonic Wars. A good empire is when all the nations within it are moderately discontented in the same way. So maybe that's the best that can be hoped for. Yes. And the interesting question is, what could be done better in the EU? And apart from, of course, that it would be easier if we had an emperor. And you are ready to answer the call if required. No, I'm probably the penultimate of all the Habsburgs.
他儿子的规则，直到最后一刻都是如此。我喜欢你引用的弗朗茨二世的话，他在拿破仑战争期间担任皇帝。一个好的帝国是当其中的所有民族都以同样的方式感到适度不满时。所以也许这就是能希望达到的最好结果了。是的。有趣的问题是，欧盟可以做得更好吗？除了当然，如果我们有一位皇帝会更容易之外。而你如果被要求，准备好响应号召了吗？不，我可能是所有哈布斯堡成员中倒数第二顺位的。
I would have to kill about 80 to 90 male Habsburgs to get to the throne. And I don't want to do that. Well, Dominic could be your man there. On the other hand, Tom, sometimes countries or other places called minor Habsburgs to take over,, it didn't go very well, if you remember. Mexico, yeah. Yes, exactly. Yeah. But subsidiarity is an important point, and it is written into the founding document of the European Union in Article 5.
我得杀掉大约80到90名男性哈布斯堡成员才能登上王位。我不想那样做。好吧，多米尼克可能是你的人选。另一方面，汤姆，有时国家或其他地方会要求次要的哈布斯堡成员去接管，如果你还记得的话，结果并不太好。墨西哥，是的。是的，完全正确。是的。但辅助性原则是一个重要的点，它被写入了欧盟的创始文件第5条中。
My country, Hungary, of course, where I'm ambassador for, very often feels stepped on their toes by Brussels and feels disrespected and feels Brussels interfering into our inner affairs. This is exactly what the Hungarians felt when the Habsburgs didn't do their subsidiarity right. And the moment that the Habsburg emperors respected the Hungarian diet, the Hungarian parliament, their legal structures, their language and all that, everything went well in the empire. But so Edward, the counter argument might be, this is obviously, we can't get too deep into the historiography of the Habsburg empire, but there has always been this argument among historians that the surging kind of passions of nationalism, the sense that as the 19th century
我的国家匈牙利，当然，我担任大使的国家，经常感到被布鲁塞尔踩了脚趾，感到不被尊重，感到布鲁塞尔干涉我们的内政。这正是当哈布斯堡家族没有正确执行辅助性原则时，匈牙利人所感受到的。而当哈布斯堡皇帝尊重匈牙利议会、他们的法律结构、他们的语言以及所有这些时，帝国的一切都进展顺利。但爱德华，反驳的观点可能是，这显然，我们不能太深入哈布斯堡帝国的史学，但历史学家中一直有一种争论，即民族主义激情的涌动，那种随着19世纪
continues, the strong sense of national identity in Hungary, in Croatia, in Transylvania, yeah, Transylvania and the Czech lands and so on. The thing that you see in those books by, I mean, you see it to some extent in those books by Miklos Banfi, those brilliant books about life in Hungarian Transylvania at the end of the empire, the sense that the idea of dynastic loyalty is actually just being completely corroded by the new power of nationalism. Does that suggest that the end of the empire was always coming? Or to go back to your previous thing, do you think that business about Franz Ferdinand and the kind of United States of Austria that he dreamed of, do you think that was really realistic? First of all, I agree, Dominic, that
的持续，匈牙利、克罗地亚、特兰西瓦尼亚，是的，特兰西瓦尼亚和捷克地区等地强烈的民族认同感。你在米克洛什·班菲（Miklos Banfi）的那些书中看到的，那些关于帝国末期匈牙利特兰西瓦尼亚生活的精彩书籍，那种王朝忠诚的观念实际上正被民族主义的新力量完全侵蚀的感觉。这是否意味着帝国的终结是必然的？或者回到你之前的话题，你认为关于弗朗茨·斐迪南和他梦想的“奥地利合众国”的事情，你认为那真的现实吗？首先，我同意，多米尼克，
you have a very strong argument. If you look at what happened in 1848, 1848, you made two brilliant episodes about 1848, was the moment where at the beginning, Franz Joseph was ready to give concessions to Hungary and the others to get peace, then realized that this would blow the empire apart and then installed a reign of terror for about 10 years at least to keep everything together. I believe that after 1867, with the Ausgleich between Austria and Hungary and with the perspective of Franz Ferdinand becoming emperor… So that for our listeners is the bit where the empire is kind of divided in two, isn't it? They're between an empire of Austria and a kingdom of Hungary. So he's now the king and emperor, and the Hungarians run their own business. What you call the Kauka imperial and royal monarchy, the emperor only being king in Hungary and emperor in Austria, and Hungary getting a lot of rights, their own rights and being
你有一个非常有力的论点。如果你看看1848年发生了什么，你做了两集关于1848年的精彩节目，那是弗朗茨·约瑟夫准备向匈牙利和其他地区做出让步以换取和平的时刻，然后意识到这会使帝国分崩离析，于是实施了至少10年的恐怖统治来维持一切。我相信在1867年奥地利和匈牙利达成妥协（Ausgleich）之后，以及弗朗茨·斐迪南即将成为皇帝的前景下……所以对于我们的听众来说，那是帝国一分为二的部分，对吧？在奥地利帝国和匈牙利王国之间。所以他现在是国王兼皇帝，而匈牙利人经营自己的事务。你所说的“帝国和王室”君主制，皇帝只是匈牙利的国王和奥地利的皇帝，匈牙利获得了许多权利，他们自己的权利，并受到
respected very strongly. And of course, all the Slavic people felt left out by that. They more or less said the Germans and the Hungarians separated the world among themselves. What about us? And of course, an improbable enthusiast for this model provided by the Habsburg monarchy is Arthur Griffith, the leader of Sinn Féin in the years before the Easter Rising. So if Sinn Féin can be fans of Habsburgs, who can't? So the fourth point you make is stand for law and justice and your subjects. And the great exemplar of that that you offer is your great, great, great grandfather, Archduke Joseph, the Palatine of Hungary, who lived between 1776 and 1847. So what is it about
非常强烈的尊重。当然，所有的斯拉夫民族都感到被排除在外。他们或多或少地说，德国人和匈牙利人瓜分了世界。我们呢？当然，哈布斯堡君主制模式的一个不可思议的拥护者是亚瑟·格里菲斯（Arthur Griffith），复活节起义前几年新芬党的领导人。所以如果新芬党都能成为哈布斯堡家族的粉丝，还有谁不能呢？所以你提出的第四点是为法律、正义和你的臣民挺身而出。你提供的伟大典范是你的高祖父，匈牙利总督约瑟夫大公，他生活在1776年至1847年之间。那么关于
him that you see as being exemplary for people? Well, he and his about 10 brothers were raised in the spirit of enlightenment. They knew that their job, wherever they were going to be sent, was to bring that country firmly into the 19th century, do everything to better the life of their subjects, and to work tirelessly for that. It's the counter-argument to the idea of the cackling evil ruler that we have nowadays. And when he arrived in Hungary in the 1790s as palatine for the emperor, he fell in love with that country, with the language, with their culture, and he went native.
他，你认为对人们来说是典范的特质是什么？好吧，他和他的大约10个兄弟是在启蒙运动的精神下长大的。他们知道他们的工作，无论他们被派往哪里，都是要把那个国家坚定地带入19世纪，尽一切努力改善臣民的生活，并为此不懈努力。这是对我们今天所拥有的那种邪恶统治者概念的反驳。当他在1790年代作为皇帝的总督来到匈牙利时，他爱上了那个国家，爱上了他们的语言、他们的文化，他变得本土化了。
Our family branch remained in Hungary until the Second World War. We became that much Hungarian. He did the difficult job of negotiating between the Hungarian leadership and the emperor. He founded the Academy of Sciences. He founded the first fire departments there. He did everything to bring the country firmly into the present and help Hungary. So he and his brothers are in the spirit of enlightenment, trying to be there for their subjects, trying to help them. And I think this is something that I see over the centuries in most Habsburgs. But of course, after enlightenment, even stronger up to the end, Habsburgs always saw themselves really as servants to their subjects.
我们的家族分支一直留在匈牙利直到第二次世界大战。我们变得非常匈牙利化。他做了在匈牙利领导层和皇帝之间进行谈判的困难工作。他创立了科学院。他在那里建立了第一个消防部门。他尽一切努力把国家坚定地带入现代并帮助匈牙利。所以他和他的兄弟们在启蒙运动的精神下，试图为他们的臣民服务，试图帮助他们。我认为这是我在几个世纪以来的大多数哈布斯堡成员身上看到的东西。但当然，在启蒙运动之后，甚至更强烈地直到最后，哈布斯堡成员总是真正地将自己视为臣民的仆人。
It sounds a bit idealistic, but it was real. So could I, just to play devil's advocate, offer two counter examples, both from the 16th century, the first being the conquest of America and the lands in America that become subject to Habsburg rule. And the second also in the 16th and going into the 17th century is what happens in the Netherlands, where there is a massive revolt against Habsburg rule. I mean, where are the Habsburgs falling down there? Are they getting it right there or not? Tom, you may notice that these two examples barely make it into my book. Yeah, we did notice that.
这听起来有点理想主义，但它是真实的。那么，为了扮演魔鬼代言人，我能提供两个反例吗？都来自16世纪，第一个是美洲的征服以及成为哈布斯堡统治对象的土地。第二个也是在16世纪到17世纪，发生在荷兰的事情，那里发生了针对哈布斯堡统治的大规模起义。我的意思是，哈布斯堡家族在哪里失败了？他们做得对吗？汤姆，你可能注意到这两个例子几乎没有出现在我的书中。是的，我们注意到了。
Perhaps there's a reason for that. I had noticed. Indeed, I think they're not mentioned at all. I would say we were learning. We were learning. Okay. That's a very fair answer. Yeah. I think that will come, Tom, as a tremendous consolation to the people of Peru and indeed the Netherlands. Okay. So number five is know who you are. And this introduces what I think is absolutely my favorite detail of Habsburg history, which is that your title, Archduke they discovered some documents in a style, if you read them in Latin, that sounds like you and me trying to write a document in Latin during school. One is a letter by Caesar about his uncle, the dux of Comus Austria, and how important it is that one should obey to him.
也许是有原因的。我注意到了。确实，我想它们根本没被提到。我会说我们在学习。我们在学习。好吧。这是一个非常公平的回答。是的。我想这对秘鲁人民，当然还有荷兰人民来说，会是一种巨大的安慰。好吧。所以第五条是“了解你是谁”。这引出了我认为绝对是我最喜欢的哈布斯堡历史细节，那就是你的头衔，大公。他们发现了一些拉丁文的文件，如果你读它们，听起来就像你和我试图在学校里写一份拉丁文文件一样。一份是凯撒关于他叔叔，科莫斯奥地利公爵的信，以及服从他是多么重要。
And the other one is a document by Nero. And all the titles are wrong when you read it. It's so ridiculous. We found those things in our documents. There was the same time where we found very old family trees going back to biblical times. Brilliant. Yeah. You've got a family tree going back to Noah. Is that correct? Yes. To Noah, of course, which makes sense because Adam and Eve doesn't really make sense because everybody descends from Adam and Eve. But Noah is pretty good as an ancestor. Definitely. And this rule is called know who you are. And you talked about discovering these documents. Of course, if I was being harsh,
另一份是尼禄的文件。当你读它时，所有的头衔都是错的。太荒谬了。我们在我们的文件中发现了这些东西。那是同一时期，我们还发现了追溯到圣经时代的非常古老的家谱。太棒了。是的，你有一个追溯到诺亚的家谱。对吗？是的，追溯到诺亚，当然，这说得通，因为亚当和夏娃说不通，因为每个人都是亚当和夏娃的后代。但诺亚作为一个祖先相当不错。绝对是。这条准则被称为“了解你是谁”。你谈到了发现这些文件。当然，如果我刻薄一点，
I might say, make up who you are. And that these documents were forgeries. Now, I know you will think this is Protestant skepticism run riot, but it's perhaps one of the great lessons of Habsburg history. Be the master of the narrative. Invent your own mythology. Dominic, I have to be very serious. These documents have been accepted by an emperor to be genuine. No matter that the emperor was a Habsburg, they were accepted by an emperor. Therefore, they have legal value. And therefore, we are archdukes. That's the first thing.
我可能会说，“编造你是谁”。这些文件是伪造的。现在，我知道你会认为这是新教怀疑论的泛滥，但这也许是哈布斯堡历史最伟大的教训之一。做叙事的主人。发明你自己的神话。多米尼克，我必须非常严肃。这些文件已经被一位皇帝接受为真实的。不管那位皇帝是不是哈布斯堡家族的人，它们都被一位皇帝接受了。因此，它们具有法律价值。因此，我们是大公。这是第一件事。
The second thing is, yes, indeed, after writing that chapter, I'm not totally adverse to people designing their own vision of who they are, if it encourages them to good things. And then you can build a bit of your own mythology. I don't have a problem with that. No, that's excellent. And you've correctly put Dominic in his place. And I wish more guests were robust with Dominic in that way. So number six is be brave in battle. You never spoke about the golden fleas, Tom. You never spoke about the golden fleas. Well, I think we could maybe talk about that when the show has ended and people aren't
第二件事是，是的，确实，在写完那一章后，我不完全反对人们设计自己是谁的愿景，如果它能鼓励他们做好的事情。然后你可以建立一点你自己的神话。我对此没有问题。不，那太棒了。你已经正确地让多米尼克各就各位了。我希望更多的嘉宾能以那种方式对待多米尼克。所以第六条是“在战斗中勇敢”。你从来没谈过金羊毛，汤姆。你从来没谈过金羊毛。好吧，我想也许当节目结束，人们不再
listening in. A discreet discussion about it. You and me, Tom. You and me, Tom. Dominic is out now. Clearly. So number six is be brave in battle. And the example you cite is Archduke Charles, son of Leopold II at the Battle of Aspern in 1809, which is basically Napoleon gets defeated, unheard of. So this is a great victory for the Austrians. Whenever I write a tweet about that, everybody always says, well, but he won the next battle and don't make such a big show out of Aspern. But that's definitely not true. It's not just wishful thinking. It was a thunder that went through all of Europe. It was unthinkable for Napoleon to lose in a land battle. And why I use this image is also because
监听的时候，我们可以谈谈那个。一个关于它的谨慎讨论。你和我，汤姆。你和我，汤姆。多米尼克现在出局了。很明显。所以第六条是“在战斗中勇敢”。你引用的例子是利奥波德二世的儿子查理大公在1809年的阿斯珀恩战役中，基本上拿破仑被击败了，闻所未闻。所以这对奥地利人来说是一场伟大的胜利。每当我写一条关于那个的推文时，每个人总是说，好吧，但他赢了下一场战役，别把阿斯珀恩吹得那么大。但这绝对不是真的。这不仅仅是一厢情愿。那是传遍整个欧洲的雷声。拿破仑在陆战中失败是不可想象的。我使用这个形象也是因为
Archduke Charles really was brave. He was incredibly brave in that battle. It was a very hard, very tough battle. It wasn't an easy victory. And it was the first time Napoleon was defeated. That really sent a message. He can be defeated. And it was the first time Napoleon was defeated. That really sent a message. He can be defeated. And it was that moment that his star began to lose his shining, I think. And just on, you were mentioning Charles's bravery. So to give listeners a sense, it's 1809. They're crossing a river, aren't they? It's a battle over a river crossing. The French look like they're going to win. I mean, there was a colossal numbers of solstice the way with these great land battles in Central Europe.
查理大公确实很勇敢。他在那场战斗中非常、非常勇敢。那是一场非常艰难、非常艰苦的战斗。那不是一场轻松的胜利。这是拿破仑第一次被击败。这确实传达了一个信息。他可以被击败。这是拿破仑第一次被击败。这确实传达了一个信息。他可以被击败。我认为正是那一刻，他的星光开始失去光芒。刚才，你提到了查理的勇敢。为了让听众有个概念，那是1809年。他们正在渡河，对吧？这是一场关于渡河的战斗。法国人看起来要赢了。我的意思是，在中欧这些伟大的陆战中，有大量的伤亡。
French end up losing 20,000 men. But at the key moment, Charles leads a kind of counter charge with the reserves. He's on a white horse. He's got a flag in his hand. It's very kind of stirring stuff. Yeah, brilliant. And isn't there a statue of him, isn't there?
法国人最终损失了2万名士兵。但在关键时刻，查理带领预备队进行了一次反冲锋。他骑着一匹白马。他手里拿着一面旗帜。这非常令人振奋。是的，太棒了。那里不是有一座他的雕像吗？
In the center, in the Heldenplatz. Yes. The center of Vienna with his flag on his horse. Yes, that exact moment. It is a very exciting moment, yeah. Although, as you said, the French did win the next battle. Of course. And then Karl had to step down from his post because he made a peace agreement with Napoleon
在中心，在英雄广场。是的。维也纳的中心，他骑在马上拿着旗帜。是的，就是那一刻。这是一个非常激动人心的时刻，是的。虽然，正如你所说，法国人确实赢了下一场战役。当然。然后卡尔不得不辞职，因为他与拿破仑达成了和平协议，
without consulting the emperor. So yes, of course, they won the next battle, but it was possible to beat Napoleon. I won't let anybody take that away from me. Okay, very good. Very strong. We'll put that in the ledger. And the final, the seventh and final rule is die well. Yes. I think we should all think a bit more about death. It gives your life perspective. It lets you question whether anything you're doing is really important. And of course, as a Catholic, I know that the moment of my death, besides also among other things about the way I will spend eternity, the Habsburgs were very aware of that. I'm just trying to bring that point home. And I've seen this put in practice because I was present at
而没有咨询皇帝。所以是的，当然，他们赢了下一场战役，但击败拿破仑是可能的。我不会让任何人夺走这一点。好吧，非常好。非常有力。我们会把它记在账上。第七条，也是最后一条准则，是“善终”。是的。我认为我们都应该多思考一下死亡。它能让你的生活有视角。它让你质疑你所做的一切是否真的重要。当然，作为一名天主教徒，我知道我死亡的那一刻，除了其他事情之外，还关乎我将如何度过永恒，哈布斯堡家族非常清楚这一点。我只是想把这一点讲清楚。我亲眼目睹了这一点，因为我出席了
the funeral of Empress Zita when she died and of Otto von Habsburg, where they both times did this famous Habsburg knocking ritual. You have a lovely description of that in your book. So this is at the Capuchin Crypt in Vienna, in the Neumarkt, in the center of the city. So tell us about the knocking ritual. What happens? The knocking ritual, first of all, you can watch it on YouTube. There are videos, both of Zita's and of Otto's funeral. And you arrive with a coffin at that church, which is on the Neumarkt. You knock at the door that leads down the stairs to the crypt. And then you have a voice from inside, a kapusin,
齐塔皇后去世时的葬礼，以及奥托·冯·哈布斯堡的葬礼，他们两次都进行了著名的哈布斯堡敲门仪式。你的书中对此有很好的描述。所以这是在维也纳新市场的嘉布遣会地下室，在城市中心。那么告诉我们关于敲门仪式。发生了什么？敲门仪式，首先，你可以在YouTube上观看。有齐塔和奥托葬礼的视频。你带着棺材到达那个位于新市场的教堂。你敲响通往地下室楼梯的门。然后里面有一个声音，一个嘉布遣会修士，
who guard, of course, the bodies of the Habsburgs in the crypt, asks who is there. And then the master of ceremony reads out the titles of the emperor, just as you did at the beginning of the show. And the voice answers, we don't know him. Then they knock again, and they read out all the achievements the emperor has done in his life. Again, the voice answers, we don't know him. The third knock comes, who is there? Then they would say, Zita, a poor, sinful woman. Then the door opens. That is the Habsburg attitude towards death in a nutshell. I give a few very nice examples, a few grandiose ones with Emperor Maximilian,
当然，他们守护着地下室里哈布斯堡家族的遗体，问是谁在那里。然后司仪读出皇帝的头衔，就像你在节目开始时做的那样。声音回答：“我们不认识他。”然后他们再次敲门，读出皇帝一生中取得的所有成就。声音再次回答：“我们不认识他。”第三次敲门声响起，“是谁在那里？”然后他们会说：“齐塔，一个可怜的罪人。”然后门开了。这就是哈布斯堡家族对死亡的态度，简而言之。我举了几个非常好的例子，几个宏大的例子，比如马克西米利安皇帝，
the way he disposed his body to be treated. That's an amazing story. He demanded that all his teeth be taken out, his hair cut off, and then his body was to be whipped and covered with lime and ash. What's all that about? Or is that perfectly reasonable in your way of thinking? We all do that. No, I think it was, as I told you, the Habsburgs were very aware that their life was being seen for many peoples like an example, like a sermon. So with every gesture around his funeral, he wanted to encourage people to die like a good Christian.
他处理自己遗体的方式。那是一个惊人的故事。他要求拔掉他所有的牙齿，剪掉他的头发，然后他的身体要被鞭打并覆盖石灰和灰烬。那是什么意思？还是在你看来那是完全合理的？我们都这样做。不，我认为，正如我告诉你的，哈布斯堡家族非常清楚他们的生活被许多人视为一个榜样，像一篇布道。所以，他葬礼周围的每一个姿态，他都想鼓励人们像一个好的基督徒一样死去。
And this was a sign of humility. I was the emperor, but I'm only a poor sinner, probably in purgatory for what I did in my life. And he wanted to make that visible. The other thing that he did was the way he was buried in the steps under the altar in Wiener Neustadt, which I saw for the first time last year. Which is, you have steps leading up to the altar in Wiener Neustadt, which I saw for the first time last year, which is, you have steps leading up to the altar. And in the second step, there's just the word Maximilian. There is no huge sarcophagus. There is no images. It's just his name. And he wanted to be buried under the altar so the priest would say mass above his chest and pray for him. And probably the most famous Habsburg death of all is the youngest daughter
这是一种谦卑的标志。我是皇帝，但我只是一个可怜的罪人，可能因为我一生中所做的事情而在炼狱中。他想让这一点显而易见。他做的另一件事是他被埋葬在维也纳新城祭坛下的台阶里，我去年第一次看到。也就是，你有通往维也纳新城祭坛的台阶，我去年第一次看到，也就是，你有通往祭坛的台阶。在第二级台阶上，只有“马克西米利安”这个词。没有巨大的石棺。没有图像。只有他的名字。他想被埋在祭坛下，这样牧师就会在他的胸口上方做弥撒并为他祈祷。可能最著名的哈布斯堡死亡是玛丽亚·特蕾莎最小的女儿，
of Maria Theresa, Maria Antonia, but better known as Marie Antoinette. Wow. That's such a story. And I didn't discover it in a Habsburg book, but I discovered it in the extremely readable autobiography of the executioner of Paris, Charles-Henri Samson, who was there during the Terreur. By the way, a book everybody should read. It's incredible. He was on the little cart rumbling to her execution. And she was very unhappy and nervous and looking around all the time at the houses around. And he didn't understand why. And then she passed one house and her face lit up. And from then on, she was in peace.
玛丽亚·安东尼娅，但更广为人知的名字是玛丽·安托瓦内特。哇。那真是一个故事。我不是在哈布斯堡的书里发现的，而是在巴黎刽子手查尔斯-亨利·桑松（Charles-Henri Samson）极其可读的自传中发现的，他在恐怖时期就在那里。顺便说一句，这是一本每个人都应该读的书。太不可思议了。他坐在去往她行刑的小车上。她非常不开心和紧张，一直在看周围的房子。他不明白为什么。然后她经过一所房子，她的脸亮了起来。从那时起，她就平静了。
And she went to her execution in total, absolute peace. And afterwards, after the revolution, he drove back to the house. He looked at the house. What is this house? He didn't find anything. And then after the revolution, he spoke with underground Catholics who told him the real story. She wasn't allowed to go to confession before her death, which for a Habsburg and for a Catholic is a horrible thing because you have to carry all the weight of your sins without being sure that they have been forgiven. So she had been told that a bishop would be standing at one of the houses and the window and give her the absolution in extremis from that window.
她以完全、绝对的平静走向了她的行刑。事后，革命结束后，他开车回到那所房子。他看着那所房子。这是什么房子？他什么也没发现。然后革命后，他与地下天主教徒交谈，他们告诉了他真实的故事。她死前不被允许忏悔，这对于哈布斯堡成员和天主教徒来说是一件可怕的事情，因为你必须背负所有罪孽的重担，而不确定它们是否已被宽恕。所以有人告诉她，一位主教将站在其中一所房子的窗户旁，从那个窗户给她临终赦免。
Of course, if the bishop would have been caught, he would immediately have been killed. It was forbidden for a Catholic bishop to be present even in Paris. And when she saw that bishop giving her the absolution, she knew it was good. She was going to death in peace with God. That's very typical for a Habsburg. And many Americans say on Twitter, I didn't know Marie Antoinette was a Habsburg. So yeah, there you have another one of those stories. Oh, very moving, very moving note on which to end, I think. So Tom, are you convinced by the seven rules? Are you going to live your own life in accordance with those Habsburg edicts? Well, I think that when I become a member of the
当然，如果主教被抓住，他会立即被杀。天主教主教甚至在巴黎出现都是被禁止的。当她看到那位主教给她赦免时，她知道一切都好了。她带着与上帝的和平走向死亡。这对哈布斯堡成员来说非常典型。许多美国人在推特上说，我不知道玛丽·安托瓦内特是哈布斯堡家族的人。所以，是的，你又听到了另一个这样的故事。哦，非常感人，非常感人的结束语，我想。那么汤姆，你被这七条准则说服了吗？你打算按照这些哈布斯堡的法令来过你自己的生活吗？好吧，我想当我成为
Order of the Golden Fleece, I will have no choice but to. Well, what I haven't told you is that I actually have another Habsburg friend. So my friend Max von Habsburg, who is a listener to the Rest is History, as you will know, Edward, he is a history teacher based in Oxford. So he is my ticket to the top. So I think that we will be hitching ourselves to rival Habsburgs. Brilliant. And the conflict will put the 30 years war into the shade. People sometimes say to me, do you think the rest of history will ever end? That's how it will end. It's a scene of Habsburg civil war.
金羊毛骑士团的一员时，我将别无选择。好吧，我还没告诉你的是，我其实还有另一个哈布斯堡朋友。所以我的朋友马克斯·冯·哈布斯堡，他是《历史的其余部分》的听众，正如你所知，爱德华，他是一位在牛津的历史老师。所以他是我的通往顶峰的门票。所以我认为我们将把自己与竞争的哈布斯堡成员联系在一起。太棒了。而冲突将使三十年战争相形见绌。人们有时问我，你认为《历史的其余部分》会结束吗？这就是它结束的方式。这是一个哈布斯堡内战的场景。
Brilliant. Edward, thank you so much for coming on the show. Your book is The Habsburg Way, Seven Rules for Turbulent Times. And I know you're too diplomatic to answer this question fully, but there must be a bit of you that thinks, you know, Europe's not in a brilliant place at the moment. Do you think maybe the return of the double-headed eagle might just be what Europe needs? If we're ever needed, we're around. In the meanwhile, we're on Twitter. Very good.
太棒了。爱德华，非常感谢你来到节目。你的书是《哈布斯堡之路：动荡时代的七条准则》。我知道你太外交了，无法完全回答这个问题，但你内心一定有一部分认为，你知道，欧洲目前的情况并不好。你认为双头鹰的回归可能正是欧洲所需要的吗？如果我们被需要，我们就在附近。在此期间，我们在推特上。非常好。
That's the perfect note on which to end. Thanks so much, Edwin. Thank you, everyone, for listening. And we will be back very soon. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Goodbye. Thank you for having me on the show i'm marina hyde and i'm richard osmond and together we host the rest is entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our q a we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club.
这是完美的结束语。非常感谢，爱德华。谢谢大家的收听。我们很快就会回来。再见。再见。再见。感谢邀请我参加节目，我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们共同主持《娱乐的其余部分》。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点演艺圈八卦的固定节目，在我们的问答环节，我们揭开娱乐的面纱，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。
If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和提前获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。